well for years now Google has been
photographing and buying photographs of
the Earth's surface taken from space and
uploading them online as part of its
Google Earth program images of the
United States are regularly updated
quite frequently with one major
exception for at least eight years
images of the Tonopah test range in
Nevada have gone without an update it's
almost as if Google is helping the
government hide something if they were
hiding something what might it be Nick
Pope is a journalist he spent many years
investigating UFO sightings for the
British government he joins us tonight
Nick thanks very much for coming on so
did did I state those facts correctly
there is out of the entire continental
United States one area that is not
updated regularly on Google Earth and
it's this test facility maintained by
the US government is that correct that
is correct yes it is very close to the
infamous area 51 which is of course
where UFO enthusiasts say that whatever
it was that crashed at Roswell in 1947
was taken the Tonopah test range is
about 70 miles away from area 51 and
again it is one of the most secret
places on the face of the planet UFO
enthusiasts and the conspiracy community
say that's where the aliens are that's
where the UFOs that we're trying to
develop a being test flown aviation
enthusiasts say no it's simply a site
where the next generation of prototype
aircraft drones and perhaps hypersonic
weapons are tested but there was a blind
spot for years is there any evidence
that the first camp is right or onto
something there any evidence that the US
government does have knowledge of UFOs
that hasn't been shared with the public
well this all ties back to these recent
revelations about the Pentagon's UFO
program and these this whole that the
rumors about area 51 and crashed UFOs
and trying to put some of this together
and fly it ourselves
those rumors had gone away but then we
we
had the story about the pentagon's
program we saw of course those videos of
the Navy Jets chasing the UFOs and we
now have some of the people involved in
that program speaking out and saying yes
there were these unknowns in our
airspace so it's not just aircraft
lights and weather balloons interesting
is there any in any indication of what
it is then if it's not just aircraft
flights and weather balloons well we
don't know and the whole trouble with
this and this this really links these
two stories of the Tonopah test range
and the pentagon program there has been
this blurring of the lines even though
the phraseology the Pentagon's
project was called advanced aerospace
threat identification program so as I
say you've got this this blurring of the
lines between what is just our
cutting-edge technology and what really
might be if some of these rumors are
true from somewhere else
what's so confusing and of course I
think that DoD the Pentagon has every
right and in fact an obligation to keep
projects is working on secret but it's
not clear why so much material so many
documents from 50 years ago 40 years ago
20 years ago would remain classified to
this day what could be the explanation
for that well first of all I absolutely
agree with you on secrecy I mean I'm not
calling for this to be opened up even
though a couple of more recent photos
have now been put on Google Earth but
everything you put out there of course
the Russians can see it the Chinese can
see it everyone can see it so we need to
be mindful of that I I don't know what
is out there and I think the good news
is that finally we're getting some US
Congress interest in this the Senate
Armed Services Committee are now looking
into those Navy videos that we've seen
and discussed and the House Armed
Services Committee they are looking at
the Pentagon's program to say what did
we get for our taxpayers dollars here
last question do you think the president
and maybe some committee chairmen would
have knowledge of this they have a right
to know do you think they do know the
answers
well again the rumors are that this is
what the space force is all about but I
I'm not so sure about that I think the
president would have to know and in his
capacity of course as commander in chief
so I hope that there are some
interesting secrets whether or not they
come out over the next few months if we
get formal congressional hearings on
this as opposed to just congressional
interest we'll wait and see yeah well
they're definitely interesting secrets
out there question yes will we find out
what they are Nick Pope I know you will
find out first and I hope you'll tell us
on the show thank you
Thanks